my name is reka welcome back to another
episode of happy wheels been a while and
you that means we have new max2play
hopefully neon bars yeah I don't know I
don't really see the point and okay I
need hundred that's a billion right I
think at least alright let's go for it
good that all you got alright here we go
Wow it what
squeezed me through it alright another
good come on we're going for the million
yeah
oh my god I'm G I'm a job god bah
look at this you're gonna be a superstar
nice dude whoa come on there we go
ah it was only epic oh yeah big come on
watch the scoring system sucks come on I
have two more chances ah I thought it
could bounce or something
alright bother me looking at yeah
everything let me kiss you alright
another kiss
all right here we go bye push bad yes
Chuck bottom god damn it
alright I guess I don't make it on the
high score god damn it alright here we
go honey could you go define what's
making that noise sound I guess I can't
do it this has been a reason I'm begging
it's that dump dump them it was a zombie
get a brain burn shut up
zombie burn ha ha Jesus Christ my wife
wants to make love and I wrote it for me
you [ __ ] blocker [ __ ] blocking zombie
come on there we go
stupid ass huh I'm up hey but I'm scared
of you teleporting I'm scared now go
ahead
alright fine BAM bad shot
what is he doing making love to him
drumming on him he's cuddling him how I
don't care let him do it I don't care
wait am i what are you doing to keep
telephone
go go kill the Sammy well I do stock up
on food alright I killed that one and
that one that's right ha ha I got the
photo Motorola alright be careful honey
are you ok dad it what what did I die
and die oh I decided [ __ ] alright
see in a second alright we're back
I lost a leg but that's ok maybe the
bridge will come back
imma come on bridge maybe I need a lot
of speed what am I doing with this
alright sup leg are you then alright
faster Vespa and jump yes nice job what
is he doing you're right my wallet no no
motor but my girl I'll kill ya best
forget him
actually I don't care I have this back
hey hey don't go back so much that's
back there we go
don't ah that jumps there makes it
impossible it's difficult it how are you
doing dragging my [ __ ] come on here we
go dad would go and now spit yeah I
should kill every each and last zombie
oh my gosh why I eat my foot woman I
always wanted you to eat my feet
there we go problem solved alright cool
ah poor guy couldn't play
[ __ ] dude weak the jump so high yes
couldn't a Wow can I take the heater I'm
riding a Segway without a fight hey miss
shower you day ah son of a [ __ ] how am
I still standing without a foot that
girl got a hurt as hell what are you
doing trying to eat a car nom nom cars
shut up you don't eat cars so help me
I'm typing there we go
this is not look good [ __ ] you twice
there we go
double spot Dora [ __ ] penis [ __ ] wait
what anything hello da my name is
Sandhya we are looking for survivors to
help us escape are you interested
definitely alright fine I don't have it
what I open oh I hardly did it out I
know but anyway it doesn't matter
sorry back man okay
and edit huh what the [ __ ] was that all
right don't move in there I will try my
best brother sure that watch you could
know I died here it [ __ ] sucks
what are you Fred I'm sorry alright
front flip no it wasn't Wow I am the man
yet what the [ __ ] I'm still riding my
god I just want to eat my own deck while
I ride a bicycle you can just like the
weirdest [ __ ] [ __ ] ever no no no no
I'm not I laid my dick whatever I ahhh
fine
whoa lag what are you doing like that
again don't tell me what I can and not
eat
wait Kant or Candide oh it's don't move
I'm I'm sorry I see you like a batch I
[ __ ] piss them okay fine I'll go oh
my god that French eyes don't close this
that's awesome oh I'm just hitting the
bicycle whoa yeah you see this [ __ ] some
awesome soccer [ __ ] ass whoa back
I haven't scored yet he said Baraga of
course I scored when you're in the gold
piece of [ __ ] all right well thanks
vagina ha awesome Oh one hand baby I
believe I can fly
what the hell flexible Hey whoa oh my
god God what what Charlie a vagina huh
rainbow vagina huh oh yeah oh okay I'm
sorry but whoever made is not made your
bra fat Sam I was [ __ ] awesome
hello a lot of my references all right
and let's go
dominoe I guess oh I'm so amazed all
right this is washing [ __ ] it goes there
and those will touch coal and that ball
and I'm guessing that ball with Josh's
dad falling too fast for this [ __ ]
I am sorry I'm waiting patiently maps
like these how does butterfly it's
possible
oh [ __ ] oh they're falling I thought I
was playing bring it back ladies
raining [ __ ] watermelons whoa why'd I
do that
breathe maybe I can I'm trying to like
come on come on you gotta get out of
here ah red fire how am I supposed to
survive kidding
come on stop no it's not possible
test your neck I think it's okay all
right here we go
whoa I'm a giraffe picture what a
meatball head are you okay
you choked on a big [ __ ] watermelon
great fight that was really racism sighs
no not really
you're you and make it whatever harsh
sorry and this is a don't move I gotta
check what my first day ah [ __ ] that
hurt
ah oh I can't dad what is that little
thing back my even talking to me I'm
obviously dead you stupid pizza hard
track I guess I got to follow the heart
oh there's the heart I can get it all
right so don't move speed branch hey I
love the head better
I'm watching you [ __ ] all right let's
follow the heart I guess a little polish
head it's like a roller coaster whoa
whoa it's a BMX map call hard is going
rid of style gotta speed up here in the
downhaul thing well it's another lope
I remember this thank you like it
identical replica I may I don't remember
this part or ever me no I don't actually
diamonds in the rough come go heart what
will happen here
it's a little heart bridge what are you
doing well I'm a heartbeat
whoa it's a tiny later another lope Oh
My Jesus I wonder what will happen in
the end maybe the heart will come back
and lump-sum whoa what are you going
that this is outside the Mack rainbow
Domino heart Oh what the hell ah nah
only for pros heart addition what why oh
well I don't play those maps because
apparently I'm not a probe
but Rob's winged rod we yeah they see me
swinging they hatin patrolling and
trying to catch me ridin swinging
chronic touch me ridin spinning trying
to catch me riding swingin tryin to
catch me ridin alright got this [ __ ]
yeah oh what the scared the [ __ ] out of
me jump scares and I don't think I can
do is that I had I don't know I whatever
head is going Jen [ __ ] me
ah why don't you loosen your arms brah
there we go hold down that [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
I don't need hold down alright yeah it's
pretty comfortable go yeah yeah
no I'm stuck [ __ ] hate money get stuck I
really suck at this but I'm trying to
like finish maps these days ah why are
you letting your arms it's the [ __ ]
there we go
whoa impressive now you have to worry
about is he holding anyway come on yes
yes [ __ ] minute no no I'm a seal I'm
a seal don't kill me don't kill me but
nobody stop losing your arms you little
[ __ ] hold down I hold down whenever
fact your mom instead
oh you're offended now come here show
come here show [ __ ] I grabbed nah I
wanted sure what she won here shoo-shoo
on you yeah all right call call head
first you yeah
dolphin style [ __ ] have you ever
heard of it Kersey don't you're not
nearly late enough don't touch them hold
up like this ah [ __ ] it's wrong
all right whatever hey I'm a box yeah
they see me boxing they bar bake baking
that I don't think that's legs they
didn't for oh no way no way Oh
I finished oh and I'm doing my 6:00
position waiting for Best Buy one day
come back to me convert child but jetty
I don't know what war water here let me
just lick this thing will and we can go
caulk I like it looks like a mixture of
a mini in it whatever [ __ ] is all right
well I think going so slowly at the
[ __ ] break
whoa here we go uphill goes faster
apparently I don't know why I love the
position this is how I Drive a car
usually that's nice you know how I do it
it's usually by dozen and marry well but
Bambi why why would you do that Bambi
that made no sense why Bambi
what is this bottle ring [ __ ] that [ __ ]
I can fight hey our watermelon helmet oh
wait I missed it huh God I got to do my
ain't no pie like a Peter path party
what about a party yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah
what a mouse eat that vest back a debt
eat that [ __ ] oh I recorded 15 minutes
well I guess I can end this episode here
so like vision you enjoyed subscribe
become a brood today and I'll see you
next episode of whatever video I try to
make that's free red hair stay awesome
bros haha boys crack happens share mode
activate
[Music]